hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play the
witch's house okay when we last left off
we had just lent a hand to the cook and
now we are wandering through with a
brand new shiny silver key with which I
imagine that I will be able to open this
door let's see if this is correct
yeah the court oh the key doesn't fit it
good
roaches why why would you do that why
would you throw roaches on me is there
another what's up hey boys n' oh I don't
want to I didn't know I can move these
chairs okay
strangely colored soup in a skull shaped
bowl
don't drink it stick your ski in it wait
no I'm gonna drink it just because
mm-hmm
drink it really drink it dammit yeah
yeah yeah oh oh that didn't work at all
[Laughter]
okie dokie
all right hang on wait hang on let me uh
hang on all right take this silver key
hit bowl with key yeah that sounds good
then put key into
oh the key turned black in soup heard an
unlocking sound somewhere that's a much
better solution than drinking the damn
poison okay so now that son of a
don't do that to me don't do that door
opened hooray
going upstairs hello baby how you doing
hmm you look so fine excuse me while I
take this one step at a time
oh I do not trust that Hello Kitty get a
decorative cat ornament gotcha
goody is that gonna slice my head off
feels like you could move in any moment
yeah you're probably right about that
one yeah look I better just walking one
block at a time just very slowly very
slowly oh okay the spider has poor eyes
you can't even tell colors apart what
does that mean oh there's a spider over
there wait what
maybe there isn't a spider over there
it's full of cobweb there's nothing to
no barrel empty okay I can't move that
one no nothing in there aha
piece of rope all right why do I need a
piece of rope that is the question it's
checking the other barrels real quick
hey the butterfly is caught in the web
of take the butterfly I got a butterfly
a huge spider web is there gonna be a
spider I knew it
damnit okay so there was a hint there
that the spider thingy couldn't tell
colors apartment doesn't want me to take
his damn butterflies able to get out of
here whole don't be locked okay good
good good I don't want to talk right
don't you move don't you dare move you
don't move
the farmer the house changes based upon
the witch's magic keys do not open doors
in the witch's house something else must
serve as a key what's the power of town
I was a rich man pulling along your car
full of trigger Scott broken down in the
woods but there came up Hansen hunter in
his dog
the rich man pleaded the haunted honor
to keep a close eye on his car which
about 200 greed the rich man went to get
a new cart meanwhile the hunter kept
watch night soon fowl and the hunter
grew worried for his elderly mother
still at home so the hunter told the dog
to watch the cart and went to him to
check out his mother man returned he saw
the dog on guard gave the dog reward for
its master a silver coin to carry any
mouth dog ran all the way home and
brought him after the coin but the
hunter flew in a rage I told you watch
her in the cart
what did you do you stole from it so the
master killed the dog I saw that in the
mirror I saw that residence burns down X
X and his wife X action founded n ring
body stab wound murdered building set
aflame acceso leaned Dollard Elwin has
been missing since supplier the police
ha I thought - I think I was supposed to
see that but yeah ok wait a minute
so earning these books isn't going well
needs something to tie them together how
about some robe
give me this yep you're welcome the book
of death that's not good that's not good
why would you give me that why I heard
something
the blood come from how'd you know I
want to save please I want to save I
want to say Oh cat you didn't see like
that thing that just walked away from
you and it was good
okay all right we saved or fine lie it's
some small text on the door
save the butterfly I don't want to I
don't want to butterfly leads to death
of me
models of in Sector lined up inside the
case okay so I got a replace the
butterfly with something else
take it cover the case won't budge well
how about I break it with my iron this
picture of a white cat done with wool
seriously that music is pretty damn good
I don't know if it's like custom or
anything but it was really good nothing
note there okay painting of a lady with
her parasol the parasol is a type of
umbrella but meant for blocking Sun I
believe a book is missing the book of
death the bukuvu da read bookshelf I
know
alright I'll read the damn book I can
hear you yelling at me read it
hoo boy ah ah stop it that's bad for you
okay that was okay but I read the damn
book yo okay douches making me read
books at death if I was in real life and
I had a book called the book of death
you would all scream until I died and
then he would be so sad that I was gone
don't read it put it on the book okay
place a book in the shelf or the little
glass case coming off no no I know who
you are
American statue
I was not what I was expecting
[Music]
why did he I thought I could loop him
around thing but he didn't he didn't he
didn't do it he did not do it he didn't
do it he didn't want to do it he didn't
want to he just didn't want to do
okay so we'll try this again Barry will
do this time okay okay okay okay don't
read that did the book of death don't
read the book on the Shelf okey-dokey
all right so we got a very quickly grab
the butterfly maybe we can get out of
here it's so creepy it's so creepy it's
so creepy on the same again okey-dokey
all right we got oh you're back are ya
okey-dokey
see kitty cat you're not worried about
okay so we gotta take this butterfly and
the replacer with a bottle butterfly and
then we'll be fine right we won't die
hey butterfly model what if I'm on one
web
okie-dokie get out of Utah ow
damn you to hell what's gonna flutters
out of my hand slips out through the
wall okay kitty cat where my shitty cat
[Music]
what is all this
sacks of grain bags of poop yo okay why
is that candelabra painted with blood
[Laughter]
that's not fair
that's not fair how is that fair I had
no idea what that sound meant is it the
only one son of a
a jute bag filled with dead cats why why
would it be filled with dead cats why
would it need to be yo hello black cat
by the way this is a witch's house oh
okay oh it's locked
what the hell what is that you can see
some sort of lever inspect bridge it's
thinner than your legged snap any second
under your wig
let's cross it yep new bird net don't do
peer though okay anyway I just want to
try every death that I possibly can I'm
gonna see that loading screen of lot
[Music]
what are you doing froggy do you like
frogs now
hey Joe
alright frog came along
for what purpose you want to see the bag
of dead cats froggy froggy you want to
see the bag of dead cats Ferrari is
happy ok alrighty then well as long as a
frogs happy oh I know what the Frog
needs to do save save save frog needs to
cross this for me give me the levers and
the probably pros go froggy go go froggy
go
you got it money boink come back froggy
come to me thank you mr. froggy I love
you hi just want that thing to throw at
me I'm not gonna go in the next year he
just yet I'm gonna cut it here isn't
nerve wrecking
surprisingly so I haven't got anything
to say about it other than what you've
already seen this is like really good
I'm very surprised I'm pleasantly
surprised this is turning out to be a
very very good horror game that I have
overlooked for far too long I've
overlooked this whole genre for far too
long so I really do appreciate you guys
who have continued to recommend it and
it finally got drilled in my brain so
thank you all so much for watching click
the annotation with more videos that
I've done and as always I will see you
in the next video
[Music]